hello and we're here with a great victor
with the black pieces against janne
pognac jordan van forest you said that
you had two wins last tournament it
seems that you have two wins per day now
uh today i had only one but yeah i
cannot complain i mean today was an
exceptionally good day i think
i don't know why why it's going so well
but i guess everything is just clicking
for me and then sometimes i can play
some good chess i guess
very good choice i'm very entertaining
just your game against osiris was just
looked like a bloodbath on the board
yeah yeah that was crazy i i guess i was
winning somewhere but
um also like the previous game was so
long i didn't have um
i wasn't as sharp i would say and then i
got very confused with all the things
going on at this rook like going from c3
to a3 and i just couldn't figure things
out quite uh correctly speaking of that
rook c3a3 i wanted to bring your
attention to a not so recent game a
certain pillsbury against alaska 1895
1896. did you know this game no you can
see this position on the board and the
cool thing was it was just your game
rook c3 rook e3 yeah it's quite amazing
i mean um i haven't seen this game
although maybe i have but it's just such
a long time ago like i must have seen it
when i was a youth when i was like very
small but other than that it doesn't
really ring a bell and yeah rook a3 here
i guess it's winning for black i mean in
the game fortunately it was not um
the game was actually very complicated
it was a brilliancy why alaska ended up
meeting pillsbury on c5 very cool game i
recommend you check it out check it out
but let's check out the game there you
destroyed your opponent
why you come up with these great ideas
rookie one such a well-known position
and today you saw we saw bishop b5
bishop e2 against
we see this bishop e6 here where else
all this creativity coming from well i
mean in classical it's very hard to be
creative these days because your
opponent has a lot of time to think but
in these rapid games you're
like you can get away with a lot more
things um especially because the
opponent just doesn't have the time to
refute the dubious lines so um or like
when they're black they cannot find a
way to make a draw all that often so i
mean here bishop e6 it's it's a little
bit dubious but i thought maybe for this
game it's gonna be interesting
it seemed like it fell apart very
quickly for him where do you think it
started to go wrong yeah i was surprised
i i mean this knight eight three knight
c4 i didn't know but um suddenly i just
got a very pleasant position and it just
collapsed but i cannot really pinpoint
his his final mistake i think he
mentioned something along the lines of
queenie one somewhere after me you can
show it um
yeah i think he said c4 he should go
queenie one here
i couldn't quite understand if he meant
queen of honor queenie one but at least
harry keeps everything together but
nonetheless with all my active piece i
should be much
better although i didn't think it was
that much better but i'm very
comfortable here with the black beast of
course and how long did it take you to
see this beautiful shot bishop takes you
to basically ending the game yeah i was
actually calculating it in a little bit
different line already like if he makes
um
instead of c4 if he plays
like let's say h3 or something yeah like
i i have this idea of already and then
after c4 is just basically provoking me
to to do this bishop takes g2 so i saw
it immediately i was just calculating if
it's like working or if i'm plundering
something but i guess it's just
completely winning for black you made it
look easy and the conversion of course
from here quite simple
expectations coming into the tournament
now that we're halfway through the rapid
have they changed
no i have still zero expectations
actually um before this i had a very
tough period in classical chess i'm just
happy to win some games again and
i'll just see how it goes but i'm very
happy for now absolutely a great
performance so far here for jordan guys
let's go back to the studio have plenty
of games left in this round well thank
you very much again our congratulations
to